let's get started so welcome to the very
final lecture of the class I hope you're
all surviving the last week and racking
up your projects so today we're going to
be hearing about the future of NLP and
deep learning so Chris is still
traveling and today we're going to be
having Kevin Clark who's one of the PhD
students in the lab in the NLP lab and
he was also one of the head TAS for the
class last year so he's very familiar
with the class as a whole so take away
Kevin okay
thanks Abby yeah it's great to be back
after being TA last year I'm really
excited today to be talking about the
future of deep learning and NLP
obviously trying to forecast the future
for deep learning or anything in that
space is really difficult because the
field is changing super quickly so as
one what reference point let's look at
what did deep learning for NLP look like
about five years ago and really a lot of
ideas that are now considered to be
pretty core techniques when we think of
deep learning and NLP didn't even exist
back then so things you weren't in this
class like seek to seek attention
mechanism large scale reading
comprehension even frameworks such as
tensor flow or pi torch didn't exist and
the point I want to make with this is
that because of this is really difficult
to look into the future and say okay
what are things going to be like what I
think we can do though is look at areas
that right now are really sort of taking
off so areas in which there's a lot been
a lot of recent success and kind of
project from that that those same areas
will likely be important in the future
and in this talk I'm going to be mostly
focusing on one key idea with key idea
which is the idea of leveraging
unlabeled examples when training our NLP
systems so I'll be talking a bit about
doing that for machine translation both
in improving the quality of translation
and even in doing translation in a
unsupervised way so that means you don't
have paired sentences with
with their translations you try to learn
a translation model only from
monolingual corpus the second thing I'll
be talking a little bit about is opening
is GPT too and in general this phenomena
are really scaling up deep learning
models I know you saw a little bit of
this in the lecture on contextual
representation but this will be a little
bit more in depth and I think these new
developments in NLP I have had some
pretty big impacts in terms of more
broadly kind of beyond even the
technology we're using and in particular
I'm starting to raise more and more
concerns about the social impact of NLP
both in water models can do and also in
kind of plans of what where people are
looking to apply these models and I
think that really has some risks
associated with it
in terms of security also in terms of
areas like bias I'm also going to talk a
bit about future areas of research these
are mostly research areas now that are
over the past year have really kind of
developed into promising areas and I
expect they will continue to be
important in the future ok start with I
want ask this question why is deep
learning been so successful recently I
like this comic here there's a
statistical learning person and they've
got some really complicated well
motivated method for doing the task they
care about and then the neural net
person just says stack more layers so so
the point I want to make here is that
deep learning has not been successful
recently because it's more theoretically
motivated or it's more sophisticated
than previous techniques in fact I would
say that actually a lot of older
statistical methods have more of a
theoretical underpinning than some of
the tricks we do in deep learning really
the thing that makes deep learning so
successful in recent years has been its
ability to scale right so neural nets as
we increase the size of the data as we
increase the size of some models they
get really big boost and accuracy
anyways other approaches do not and if
you look to the 80s and 90s
there was actually plenty of research
and neural nets going on but it hadn't
doesn't have a hype around it that it
does now and that seems likely to be
because in the past there wasn't the
same resources in terms of computers in
terms of data and I'm only now after
we've reached sort of an inflection
point where we can really take advantage
of scale and our deep learning models
have we start to see it become a really
successful paradigm for machine learning
if we look at big deep learning success
stories I think you can see kind of this
idea play out right so here are three of
what are arguably the most famous
successes of deep learning right so
there's image recognition where before
people use very highly engineered
features to classify images and now
neural nets are much superior to those
methods machine translation has really
closed the gap between phrase based
systems and human quality translation so
this is widely used in things like
Google Translate on the quality has
actually gotten a lot better over the
past five years
another example that had a lot of hype
around it is game playing so there's
been work on Atari games there's been
alphago more recently there's been a
fast are and open AI 5 if you look at
all three of these cases underlying
these successes is really large amounts
of data
right so for image net for image
recognition there is the image net data
set which is 14 million images machine
translation data sets often have
millions of examples for game playing
you can actually generate as much
training data as you want essentially
just by running your agent within the
game over and over again so if we if we
look to NLP the story is quite a bit
different for a lot of tasks right so if
you look at even pretty core kind of
popular tasks to sake reading
comprehension in English data sets like
squad or in the order of like a hundred
thousand examples which is considerably
less than the millions or tens of
millions of examples
that these previous successes have have
benefited from and that's of course only
for English right there are thousands of
other languages and this is I think a a
problem with NLP data as it exists today
the vast majority of data is in English
when in reality fewer than 10% of the
world's population speak English as
their first language so these problems
with small datasets are only compounded
if you look at the full spectrum of
languages and that exists so so what do
we do when we're limited by this data
but we want to take advantage of deep
learning scale and train the biggest
models we can the the popular solution
that's especially how recent success is
using unlabeled data because unlike
label data unlabeled data is very easy
to acquire for language you can just go
to the Internet you can go to books you
can get lots of text whereas label data
usually requires at the least
crowdsourcing examples in some cases you
even require someone who's an expert in
something like linguistics to to
annotate that data okay so this first
part of the talk is going to be applying
this idea of leveraging unlabeled data
to improve our NLP models to the task of
machine translation so let's talk about
machine translation data it is true that
there do exist quite large data sets for
machine translation those data sets
don't exist because NLP researchers have
annotated texts for the purpose of
training their models right they exist
because in various settings translation
is done just because it's useful so for
example Proceedings of the European
Parliament on Proceedings of the United
Nations some new sites they translate
their articles into many languages so
really the machine translation data we
use to train our models are often more
of byproducts of existing cases where
translation is wanted rather than kind
of a full sampling of the sort of text
we see in the world so that means number
one is
limited in domain right so it's not easy
to find translated tweets unless you
happen to work for Twitter in addition
to that there's limitations in terms of
the languages that are covered right so
some languages say European languages
there's a lot of translation data for
other languages there's much less so in
these settings where we want to work on
a different domain or what we want to
work with a low resource language we're
limited by label data but what we can do
is pretty easily find unlabeled data so
it's actually a pretty solve problem
maybe not a hundred percent but we can
with good accuracy look at some text and
decide what language it's in train a
classifier to do that so this means it's
really easy to find data in any language
you care about because you can just go
on the web and essentially search for
data in that language and acquire a
large corpus of monolingual data okay
I'm now going into the first approach
I'm going to talk about on using
unlabeled data to improve machine
translation models this technique is
called pre training and it's really
reminiscent of ideas like Elmo
the idea is to pre train by doing
language modeling so if we have two
languages we're interested in
translating from one into the other
we'll collect large data sets for both
of those languages and then we can train
two language models one each on that
data and then we can use those pre
trained language models as
initialization for a machine translation
system so the encoder will get
initialized with the weights of the
language model trained on the source
side language the decoder will get
initialized with weights trained on the
target size language and this will
improve the performance of your model
because during this pre-training we hope
that our language models will be
learning useful information such as you
know the meaning of words or the kind of
structure of the language they're
processing and this can down the line
help the machine translation model
when we fine-tune it let me pause here
and ask if there are any questions and
just in general feel free to ask
questions throughout this talk okay so
so here is a plot showing some results
of this pre training technique so this
is English to German translation the
x-axis is how much training data as in
supervised training data you provide
these models but of course they also
have large amounts of monolingual data
for this pre training step and you can
see that this works pretty well right so
you got about two blue points increase
in performance so that's this red line
above the blue line when doing this pre
training technique and not too
surprisingly this gain is especially
large when the amount of label data is
small there is a problem with pre
training which I want to address which
is that in pre training you have these
two separate language models and there's
never really any interaction between the
two when you're running them on the
unlabeled corpus so here's a simple
technique that tries to solve this
problem and it's called self training
the idea is given a sentence from our
monolingual corpus so in this case I
travel to Belgium that's an English
sentence we won't have a human provided
translation for this sentence but what
we can do is we can run our machine
translation model and we'll get a
translation in the target language since
this is from a machine learning model it
won't be perfect but we can hope that
maybe our model can still learn from
this kind of noisy labeled example right
so we we treat our original monolingual
sentence and it's machine provided
translation as though it were a human
provided translation and trained our
machine learning model as normal on this
example
I think this seems pretty strange
actually as as a method when you first
see it because it seems really circular
right so if you look at this the
translation that the model is being
trained to produce is actually exactly
what it already produces to begin with
right because this translation came from
our model in the first place so actually
in practice this is not a technique
that's very widely used due to this
problem but it motivates another
technique called back translation and
this technique is really a very popular
solution to that problem and it's a
method that has had a lot of success in
using unlabeled data for translation um
so here's the approach rather than only
having our translation system that goes
from source language to target language
we're also going to train a model that
goes from our target language to our
source language so in this case if if at
the end of the day we want a French to
English model we're going to start by
actually training and English to French
model and then we can do something
that's a lot like self labeling so we
take a English sentence we run our
English to French model and translate it
the difference to what we did before is
that we're actually gonna switch the
source and target side so now in this
case the French sentence is the source
sequence the target sequence is our
original English sentence that came from
our monolingual corpora and now we're
training the language that machine
translation system that goes the other
direction so that goes French to English
so so why do we think this will work
better number one there's no longer this
kind of circularity to the training
because what the model is being trained
on is the output of a completely
different model another thing that I
think is pretty crucial here is that the
translations the the model is trained to
produce so the things that the decoder
is actually learning to generate are
never bad translations right so if you
look at this example the the target
sequence for a French to English model I
travel to Belgium that originally came
from our monolingual corpus
so I think intuitively this makes sense
is that if we want to train a good
translation model it's probably okay to
expose it to noisy inputs so we exposed
it to the output of a system that's
English to French it might not be
perfect but what we don't want to do is
expose it to poor target sequences
because then it won't where and how to
generate in that language effectively
any questions on back translation before
I get to results I'm sure this is
assuming we have a large corpus of
unlabeled data and we want to be using
it to help our translation model does
that does that make sense maybe you
could clarify the question yeah that's
right so we have a big corpus of English
which includes the sentence I traveled
to Belgium and we don't know the
translations but we'd still like to use
this data yet another question yeah
that's a good question is how do you
avoid both the models let's say so we're
blowing up and producing garbage and
then they're just feeding garbage to
each other the answer is that there is
some amount of label data here as well
so on one label data you do this but on
label data you do standard training and
that way you avoid you make sure you
kind of keep the models on track because
they still have to fit to the label data
yeah another question yeah that is a
good question and I think that's
basically almost like a hyper parameter
you can tweak so I think a pretty common
thing to do is first train two models
only on label data then label so then do
back translation over a large corpus and
kind of repeat that process over and
over again so each iteration you train
on the label data label some unlabeled
data and now you have more data to work
with but I think there would be many
kinds of scheduling that would be
effective here
okay another question if you have a very
good French to English model you could
try to look up or to test them it's a
good French English model you can try to
look up the original source and see if
it matches
yeah I'm not I'm not quite sure are you
suggesting going like English to French
to English and seeing if I see yeah I'm
yeah that's a really interesting idea
and we're actually gonna talk a little
bit about this sort of it's called cycle
consistency this idea later in this talk
okay I'm gonna move on to the results so
here's the method for using unlabeled
data to improve translation how well
does it do the answer is that the
improvements are at least to me they
were surprisingly extremely good right
so this is for English to German
translation this is from some work by
Facebook so that you use five million
labeled sentence pairs but they also use
230 monolingual sentences so sentences
without translations and you can see
that compared to previous
state-of-the-art they get six blue
points improvement which if you compare
it to most previous research on mystery
machine translation is a really big game
right so even something like the
invention of the transformer which most
people would consider to be a really
significant research development and NLP
that improved over prior works by about
two and a half blue points and here
without doing any sort of fancy model
design just by using way more data we
got actually much larger improvements
okay so an interesting question to think
about is suppose we only have our
monolingual corpora so we don't have any
sentences that have been human
translated we just have sentences in two
languages so the scenario you can sort
of imagine is suppose an alien comes
down and starts talking to you and it's
a weird alien language and it talks a
lot would you eventually be able to
translate what it's saying to English
just by having a really large amount of
data
so I'm gonna start with a simpler task
than full-on translating when you only
have unlabeled sentences instead of
doing sentence the sentence translation
let's start by only worrying about word
to word translation um so the goal here
is given a word in one language finest
translation but without using any label
data and the message the method we're
going to use to try to solve this task
is called cross lingual embeddings so
the goal is to wear in word vectors for
words in both languages and we like
those word vectors to have all the nice
properties you've already learned about
we're doctors having but we also want
word vectors for a particular language
to be close to the word vector of its
translation so I'm not sure if it's
visible in this figure but this physic
figure shows a large number of English
and I think German words and you can see
that the each English word has its
corresponding German word nearby to it
in its embedding space so if we learn
embeddings like this then it's pretty
easy to do word to word translation we
just pick an english word we find the
nearest german word in this joint
embedding space and that will give us a
translation for the english word our key
method for the key assumption that we're
going to be using to solve this is that
even though if you run word Tyvek twice
you'll get really different embeddings
the structure of that embedding space
has a lot of regularity to it and we can
take advantage of that regularity to
help find when an alignment between
those embedding spaces so to be kind of
more concrete here here is a picture of
two sets of word embedding so in red we
have English words in blue we have
Italian words and although the vector
spaces right now look very different to
each other the you can see that they
have a really similar structure right so
you would imagine distances are kind of
similar that the distance from cat and
feline in the English embedding space
should be pretty similar to the distance
between gato and Foligno in the Italian
space and this kind of motivates an
algorithm for learning these cross
lingual embeddings so so here's the idea
what we're going to try to do is learn
what's essentially a rotation such that
we can transform our set of English
embeddings
so that they match up with our Italian
bed embeddings so mathematically what
this means is we're gonna learn a matrix
W such that if we take let's say the
word vector for cat in English and we
multiply it by W we end up with the
vector for gato in Spanish or Italian
and a detail here is that we're going to
constrain W to be orthogonal and what
that means geometrically is just that W
is only going to be doing a rotation to
the vectors in X and it's not going to
be doing some other weirder
transformation so this is our goal so
we're in this w
next I'm going to be talk about talking
about how actually do we learn this w
and there's actually a bunch of
techniques for learning this w matrix
but here is one of them that I think is
quite clever it's called adversarial
training so it works as follows is in
addition to trying to learn this W
matrix we're also going to be trying to
learn a model that is called a
discriminator and what it'll do is take
a vector and it'll try to predict is
that vector originally an English word
embedding or is it originally an Italian
word embedding in other words if you
think about the diagram what we're
asking our discriminator to do is it's
given one of these points and is trying
to predict is it basically a red point
so an English word originally or is it a
blue point so if we have no W matrix and
this is a really easy task for the
discriminator because
the word embeddings for English and
Italian are clearly separated however if
we learn a W matrix that succeeds in
aligning all these embeddings on top of
each other then our discriminator will
never do a good job right we can we can
imagine it'll never really do better
than 50% because given a vector force a
cat it won't know is that the vector for
cat that's been transformed by w or is
it actually the vector for gato because
in this case those two vectors are
aligned so they're on top of each other
so during training you first you
alternate between training the
discriminator a little bit which means
making sure it's as good as possible at
distinguishing the English from Italian
words and then you train the W and the
goal for training W is to essentially
confuse the discriminator as much as
possible so you want to have a situation
where you can't with this machine
learning model figure out if a word
embedding actually was originally from
English or if it's an Italian word
vector and so at the end of the day you
have you have vectors that are kind of
aligned with each other any questions
about this approach okay here there's a
link to a paper with more details
there's actually a kind of a range of
other tricks you can do but this is kind
of a key idea
okay so that was doing word to word
unsupervised translation how do we do
full sentence to sentence translation so
we're going to use as standard sort of
seek to seek model without even an
attention mechanism there's one change
to the standard seek to seek model going
on here which is that we're going to use
the same encoder and decoder regardless
of the input and output languages so you
can see in this example we could give
the encoder an English sentence we could
also give it a French sentence and it'll
have these cross lingual embedding so
it'll
vector representations for English words
and French words which means it can
handle sort of any input for the decoder
we need to give us some information
about what language is it supposed to
generate in is it going to generate in
French or English so the way that is
done is by feeding in a special token
which here is f R and bracket brackets
to represent French that tells the model
okay you should generate in French now
here then this figure it's only French
but you could imagine also feeding this
model English in brackets and then
that'll tell it to generate English and
one thing you can see is that you could
use this sort of model to generate do
you go from English to French um you
could also use this model as an
autoencoder right so at the bottom it's
taking in a French sentence as input and
it's just generating French as output
which here means just reproducing the
original input sequence so just a small
change the standard seek to seek here's
how we're going to train the steek to
seek model there's going to be two
training objectives and I'll explain
sort of why they're present in this
model in just a few slides for now let's
just say what they are so the first one
is called a denoising auto-encoder what
we're gonna train our model to do in
this case is take a sentence so and here
it's going to be an English sentence but
it could also be a French sentence we're
going to scramble up the words a little
bit and then we're going to ask the
model to denoise that sentence which in
other words means regenerating what the
sentence actually was before it was
scrambled and maybe one idea of why this
would be a useful training objective is
that since we have an encoder decoder
without detention the encoder is
converting the entirety of the source
sentence into a single vector what an
auto encoder does is ensure that that
vector contains all the information
about the sentence such that we are able
to recover what the original sentence
was
from the vector produced by the encoder
so that was objective one I'm training
objective two is now we're actually
going to be trying to do translation but
as before we're going to be using this
back translation idea so remember we
only have unlabeled sentences we don't
have any human provided translations but
what we can still do is given a let's
say an English sentence or also a French
sentence given a French sentence we can
translate it to English using our model
in its current state and then we can ask
that model to translate from English or
translate that yet translate that
English back into French so what you can
imagine is in the setting the input
sequence is going to be somewhat messed
up because it's the output of our
imperfect machine learning model so here
the input sequence is just I am student
a word has been dropped but we're now
going to Train it to even with this kind
of bad input to reproduce the original
French sentence from our corpus of
monolingual on French text let me let me
pause here actually and ask for
questions too
yeah that's a good question so this is
going back to earlier when there was a
word word translation why would we
constrain that w matrix to be orthogonal
essentially that's right it's to avoid
overfitting and in particular it's
making this assumption that our
embedding spaces are so similar that
there's actually just a rotation that
distinguishes our word vectors in
English versus our word vectors in
Italian I think there has been there
have been results that don't include
that orthogonality constraint and I
think it's slightly hurts performance to
not have that in there okay
so so continuing with unsupervised
machine translation I I gave a training
method I didn't quite explain why it
would work so so here is some more
intuition for for this idea so remember
we're going to initialize our machine
translation model with these cross
lingual embeddings which mean the
English and French word should look
close to identically we're also using
the shared encoder so that means if you
think about it at the top we have just a
encoding objective and we can certainly
believe that our model can learn this
it's a pretty simple task
now imagine we're giving our model a
French sentence as input instead since
the embeddings are going to look pretty
similar and since the encoder is the
same it's pretty likely that the models
representation of this french sentence
should actually be very similar to the
representation of the english sentence
so when this representation is passed
into the decoder we can hope that we'll
get the same output as before so here's
like serve as a starting point we can
hope that our model already is able to
have some translation capability another
way of thinking about this is that what
we really want our model to do is to be
able to encode
a sentence such that that representation
is sort of a universal kind of inter
linguist or a universal universal
representation of that sentence that
doesn't that's not specific to the
language and so here's kind of a picture
that's trying to get at this
so our auto encoder and our here and our
back translation example I'm here that
target sequence is the same so what that
essentially means is that the vectors
for the English sentence and the front
sentence are going to be trained to be
the same right because if they were
different our decoder would be
generating different outputs on these
two examples so this is just another
sort of intuition is that what our model
is trying to learn here is kind of a way
of encoding the information of a
sentence and a vector but in a way that
is language agnostic any more questions
about unsupervised machine translation
okay so going on to results of this
approach here the horizontal lines are
the results of an unsupervised machine
translation model the lines that go up
are for a supervised machine translation
model as we give it more and more data
right so unsurprisingly given a large
amount of supervised data the supervised
machine translation models work much
better than the unsupervised machine
translation model but the unsupervised
machine translation model actually still
does quite well so if you see it around
ten thousand to a hundred thousand
training examples it actually does just
as well or better than supervised
translation and I think that's a really
promising result because if you think of
low resource settings where there isn't
much labeled examples that suddenly
becomes really nice that you can perform
this well without even needing to use a
training set another thing kind of fun
you can do with a unsupervised machine
translation model is attribute transfer
so basically you can take collections of
text that split by any attribute you
want so for example you could go on
Twitter look at hashtags to decide which
tweets are annoyed and which tweets are
relaxed and then you can treat those two
corpora as texts as though they were two
different languages and you can train an
unsupervised machine translation model
to convert from one to the other and you
can see these examples the model
actually does a pretty good job of sort
of minimally changing the sentence kind
of preserving a lot of that sentences
original semantics such that the target
attribute is changed I also want to
throw a little bit of cold water on this
idea so I do think it's really exciting
and an almost kind of mind-blowing that
you can do this translation without
label data certainly right it's really
hard to imagine someone giving me a
bunch of books in Italian and say okay
we're in Italian without you know
teaching you how to specifically do the
translation
but even though these methods so promise
mostly they have shown promise on
languages that are quite closely related
so those previous results those were all
some combination of English to French or
English to German or so on and those
languages are quite similar so if you
look at a different language pair or
let's say English to Turkish where the
linguistics in those two languages are
quite different these methods do still
work to some extent so they get around
five blue points let's say but they
don't work nearly as well as they do in
the in the other settings right so
there's still a huge gap to purely
supervised learning right so we're
probably not you know quite at this
stage where an alien could come down and
it's sort of no problem let's use our
unsupervised machine translation system
but I still think it's pretty exciting
progress yeah question
which my lina to superpose works right
because my original thought was that if
you took for example like life which
doesn't have a word or you know let some
water come onto the cart I thought that
would do more clearly but do you think
English not better to plan because
they're most related and worse the
Turkish or is the other way around I
would expect English to map quite a lot
better to Aladdin and I think part of
the issue here is that the difficulty in
translation I think is not really at the
word level so I mean that certainly is
an issue that words exist in one
language that don't exist in another but
I think actually more substantial
differences between languages at the
level of like syntax or you know
semantics right how ideas are expressed
so so I think I would expect Italia
Latin to have you know relatively
similar syntax to English compared to
say Turkish and I imagine that is
probably the bigger obstacle for
unsupervised machine translation models
I'm going to really quickly go into this
last recent research paper which is
basically taking Bert which which you've
learned about correct yes okay and
making it cross lingual so here's what
regular burr is right we have a sequence
of sentences in English we're going to
mask out some of the words and we're
gonna ask Bert which is our transformer
model to essentially fill in the blanks
and predict what were the words that
were dropped out what actually here has
already been done by Google is training
a multilingual Bert so what they did
essentially is concatenate a whole bunch
of corpora and different languages and
then train one model doing using this
mask
LM objective on all of that text at once
and that's a publicly release model the
the new kind of extension to this that
has recently been proposed by Facebook
is to actually combine this masks LM
training objective
with translation so what they do is
sometimes give this model a in this case
the sequence in English and a sequence
in French drop out some of the words and
just as before ask the model to fill it
in and the motivation here is that this
will much better cause the model to
understand the relation between these
two languages because if you're trying
to find a fill in a English word that's
been dropped the best way to do it if
you have a translation is look at the
French side and try to find that word
hopefully that one hasn't been dropped
as well and then you can much more
easily fill in the blank and this
actually leads to very substantial
improvements in unsupervised machine
translation so just like Bert is used
for other toss in NLP they basically
take this cross lingual Bert they use it
as initialization for a unsupervised
machine translation system and they get
you know really large gains on the order
of ten blue points such that the gap
between unsupervised machine translation
and the current supervised state
of-the-art is much smaller so this is a
pretty recent idea but I think it also
shows promise and really improving the
quality of translation through using
unlabeled data although I guess yeah I
guess in this case of Bert they are
using label translation data as well any
any questions about this okay so that is
all I'm going to say about using
unlabeled data for translation the next
part of this talk is about what happens
if we really scale up these unsupervised
language models so in particular I'm
going to talk about GPT 2 which is a new
model by open AI that's essentially a
really giant language model and I think
it has some interesting implications so
first of all here's just the sizes of a
bunch of different NLP models and you
know maybe a couple years ago that the
standard sort of LS TM medium sized
model was on the order of about 10
parameters where temper we're parameter
is just you know a single wait let's say
in the neural net Elmo and GPT so the
original open AI paper before they did
this GP feet t2 and we're about ten
times bigger than that GPT two is about
another order of magnitude bigger one
kind of interesting comparison point
here is that GPT 2 which is a 1.5
billion parameters actually as more
parameters than a honeybee brain has
synapses so that sounds kind of
impressive right you know honeybees are
not the smartest of animals but they can
still fly around and find nectar or
whatever but you know of course this
isn't really an apples to apples
comparison right so as synapse any
weight and a neural net are really quite
different but I just think it's one kind
of interesting milestone let's say in
terms of model size that has been
surpassed
one thing to point out here is that this
increasing scaling of deep learning is
really a general trend in all of machine
learning so beyond NLP so this plot is
showing time on the x axis and the y
axis is log scaled the amount of
petaflop used to train this model so
what this means is that the trend at
least currently is that there is
exponential growth and how much compute
power I'm worth throwing out our machine
learning models I guess it is kind of
unclear you know will exponential growth
continue but certainly there's rapid
growth in the size of our models and
it's leading to some really amazing
results right so here are results not
from language but revision this is a
generative adversarial Network that's
been trained on a lot of data and it's
been trained at really large scale so
it's a big model kind of in between the
size of Elmo and Bert let's say and
these photos here are actually
productions of the model so those aren't
real photos those are things the model
is just kind of hallucinating out of
thin air and at least to me they look
essentially photorealistic there's also
a website that
is fun to look at if you're not if
you're interested which is this person
does not exist calm so if you go there
you'll see a very convincing photo of a
person but it's not a real photo it's
again like a hallucinating image
produced by again we're also seeing
really huge models being used for image
recognition so this is recent work by
Google where they trained an image net
model with half a billion parameters so
that's bigger than Burt but not as big
as GPT - this plot here is showing log
scaled number of parameters on the
x-axis and then accuracy at image now on
the y-axis and sort of unsurprisingly
bigger models perform better and there
seems to actually be a pretty consistent
trend here which is accuracies
increasing with a log of the the model
size I want to go into a little bit more
detail how is it possible that we can
scale up models and train models at such
a large extent one answer is just better
hardware and in particular there's a
growing number of companies that are
developing hardware specifically for
deep learning so these are even more
kind of constrained in the kind of
operations they can do than a GPU but
they do those operations even faster so
Google's tensor processing units is one
example there are actually a bunch of
other companies working on this idea the
other way to scale up models is by
taking advantage of parallelism and
there's two kinds of parallelism that I
want to talk about very briefly so one
is data parallelism in this case each of
your let's say GPUs will have a copy of
the model and what you essentially do is
split the mini batch that you're
training on across these different
models so if you have let's say 16 GPUs
and each of them see a batch size of 32
you can aggregate their gradients of
these 16 if you do backprop on these 16
GPUs and you end up with effectively
about size of 512 so this allows you to
train models much faster the other kind
of parallelism that's growing in
importance is model print parallel
so eventually models get so big that
they can't even fit on a single GPU and
they can't even do a batch size of one
in this case you actually need to split
up the model across multiple compute on
multiple computer you nuts and that's
what's done for models kind of the size
of let's say GPT two there are new
frameworks such as mesh tensorflow
which are basically designed to make
this sort of model parallelism easier
okay so on to GPT to I know you already
saw this a little bit in the
contextualized embeddings lecture but
I'm going to go into some more depth
here so so essentially it's a really
large transformer language model so
there's nothing really kind of novel
here in terms of new training algorithms
or in terms of the loss function or
anything like that the thing that makes
it different from prior work is that
it's just really really big it's trained
on a correspondingly huge amount of text
so it's trained on 40 gigabytes and
that's roughly ten times larger than
previous language models have been
trained on when you have that size of
data set the only way to get that much
text is the century to go to the web so
one thing opening I put quite a bit of
effort into you when they're developing
this network was to ensure that that
text was pretty high quality and they
did that in a kind of interesting way
they looked at reddit which is this
website where people can vote on links
and then they said if a link has a lot
of votes then it's probably sort of a
decent link there's probably you know
reasonable text there for a model to
learn okay so if we have this super huge
language model like GPT two on this
question of what can you actually do
with it well obviously if you have a
language model you can do language
modeling with it
but one thing kind of interestingly
interesting is that you can run this
language model on
existing benchmarks for language
modeling and a get state-of-the-art
perplexity on these benchmarks even
though it never sees the training data
for these benchmarks right so normally
if you want to say evaluate your a
language model on the pen tree Bank you
first train on the penn treebank
and then you evaluate on this held-out
set in this case GPT - just by virtue of
having seen so much text and being such
a large model outperforms all these
other prior works even though it's not
seeing that data on a bunch of different
language modeling benchmarks but there's
a bunch of other interesting experiments
that openly I ran with this language
modeling and these were based on zero
shot learning so zero shot learning just
means trying to do a task without ever
training on it and the way you can do
this with a language model is by
designing a prompt you feed into the
language model and then have it just
generate from there and hopefully it
generates something relevant to the task
you're trying to solve so for example
for reading comprehension what you can
do is take the context paragraph
concatenate the question to it and then
add a colon which is a way I guess of
telling the model okay you should be
producing an answer to this question and
then just have it generate text and
perhaps it'll generate something that is
actually answering the question and is
paying attention to the context and
similarly for summarization you can do
the article then TLDR and perhaps the
model will produce a summary you can
even do translation where you give the
model some exist of known English to
French translations so you sort of prime
it to tell it that it should be doing
translation and then you give it the
source sequence equals blank and have it
just run and perhaps it'll generate the
sequence in the target language okay so
so here what the results look like for
all of these the x-axis is large is log
scaled model size
y-axis is accuracy and the dotted lines
basically correspond to existing works
on these tasks so for most of these
tasks GP t2 is quite a bit below
existing systems but there's of course
this big difference right existing
systems are trained specifically to do
whatever task they're being evaluated on
where GP t2 is only trained to do
language modeling and as it learns
language modeling it's sort of picking
up on these other tasks so right so for
example it does English to French
machine translation not as well as
standard unsupervised machine
translation which is those dotted lines
but it still is still does quite well
and one thing kind of interesting is the
trend line right for almost all of these
tasks performance is getting much better
as the model increases in size I think
particularly interesting one of these
tasks is machine translation right so
the question is how can it be doing
machine translation when all we're
giving it as a bunch of web pages and
those web pages are almost all in
English and yet somehow it sort of
magically picks up a little bit of
machine translation right so it's not a
great model but it can still you know do
a decent job in some cases and the
answer is that if you look at this giant
corpus of English occasionally within
within that corpus you see examples of
translations right so you see a French
idiom and it's translation or a quote
from someone who's French and then the
translation in English and kind of
amazingly I think this big model sees
enough of these examples that it
actually starts to learn how to generate
French even though that wasn't really
sort of an intended part of its training
another interesting thing to dig a bit
more into is its ability to do question
answering so a simple baseline for
question answering gets about 1%
accuracy GPT - barely does better at 4
percent accuracy so
this isn't like you know super amazing
we solve question answering but it's
still pretty interesting in that if you
look at answers the models most
confident about you can see that it's
sort of has learned some facts about the
world right so it's learnt that Charles
Darwin wrote Origin of Species normally
in the history of NLP if you want to get
kind of world knowledge into an NLP
system you'd need something like a big
database of facts and even though this
is still kind of very early stages and
that there's still a huge gap between
four percent accuracy and the you know
seventy percent or so that state of the
art open domain question answering
systems can do it it still can pick up
some world knowledge just by reading a
lot of text without kind of explicitly
having that knowledge put into the model
any questions by the way on GPT 2 so far
ok so one question that's interesting to
think about is what happens if a models
get even bigger
so here I've done the very scientific
thing of drawing some lines in
PowerPoint and seeing where they meet up
and you can see that if the trend holds
at about 1 trillion parameters we get to
human level reading comprehension
performance so if that's true would be
really astonishing I actually do expect
that a 1/2 trillion parameter model
would be attainable and I don't know 10
years or so but of course right the
trend isn't clear so if you look at
summarization for example it seems like
performance is already topped out so I
think this will be a really interesting
thing kind of going forward I'm looking
at the future of NLP is how this scaling
will change the way NLP is approached
the other interesting thing about GPT 2
was its reaction from the media and also
from other researchers and the real
cause of a lot of the the controversy
about it was this statement from opening
I they said that we're not going to
release
our full language model because it's too
dangerous you know our language model is
too good so the media really enjoyed
this and you know said that machine
learning is going to break the internet
there's also some pretty interesting
reaction from researchers right so
there's some kind of tongue-in-cheek
responses here right you know I trained
a model and amnesty is it too dangerous
for me to release it and similarly we've
done really great work but we can't
release it it's too dangerous so you're
just gonna have to trust us on this
looking at more kind of reasoned debate
about this issue you still see articles
arguing both sides so these are two
argue articles from the gradient which
is a sort of machine learning newsletter
and they're or arguing precisely
opposite sides of this issue should it
be released or not so I guess I can
briefly go over a few arguments for or
against this kind of a lot of debate
about this and I don't want to go too
deep into a controversial issue but
here's a long list of kind of things
people have said about this right so
here's why you should release you know
one complaint is that is this model
really that special there's nothing new
going on here it's just ten times bigger
than previous models and there's also so
arguments that even if this one isn't
released you know in five years
everybody can train a model this good
and actually if you look at image
recognition or look at images and speech
data it already is possible to
synthesize highly convincing fake images
and fake speech so it's kind of what
makes this thing different from those
other those other systems and speaking
of other systems right Photoshop is
existed for a long time so we can
already convincingly fake images people
have just learnt to adjust and learn
that you shouldn't always trust what's
in an image because it may have been
altered in some way on the other hand
you could say okay Photoshop exists
you can't sort of scale up Photoshop and
start mass producing fake content the
way you can with this sort of model and
they pointed the danger of fake news
fake reviews in general just aster
turfing which means basically creating
fake user content that's supporting a
view you want other people to hold this
is actually something that's already
done pretty widely by country companies
and governments so there's a lot of
evidence for this but they're of course
hiring people to write all these
comments and news articles let's say and
we don't want to make their job any
easier by producing a machine that could
potentially do this so I'm not really
gonna take a side here there's still a
lot of debate about this I think you
know the main the main takeaway here is
that as a community people and machine
learning and NLP don't really have a
handle on this why we're sort of caught
by surprise by opening eyes decision
here and that means that you know there
really is some figuring out that needs
to be done on what exactly is
responsible to release publicly what
kind of research problems should we be
working on and so on so yeah any
questions about this this reaction or
this debate in general okay I think
something are rising from this debate is
the question of should really the ml
people be the people making these sort
of decisions or is there a need for more
interdisciplinary science where we look
at experts and say computer security
people from Social Sciences you know
people who are experts in ethics to look
at these decisions right so GP t2 is
definitely one example of where suddenly
it seems like our NLP technology has a
lot of pitfalls right where they could
be used in a malicious way or they could
cause damage and I think this trend is
only going to increase if you look at
kind of areas of
and I'll pee that people are working on
increasingly people are working on
really high stakes applications of NLP
and those often have really big
ramifications especially if you think
from the angle of a bias and fairness so
so let's let's go over a couple examples
of this one so some some areas where
this is happening as people are looking
at em and I'll P to look at judicial
decision so for example should this
person get bail or not for hiring
decisions right so you look at someone's
resume you're on NLP on it and then you
make a decision automatically should we
throw out this resume or not so do some
sort of screening grading tests if you
take the GRE your tests will be graded
by a machine a person will also look at
it but nevertheless that's you know a
sometimes very impactful part of your
life when it's when does to test that in
you know affects your acceptance into a
school let's say so I think there is are
some some good size of using machine
learning in these kinds of contexts so
one is that we can pretty quickly
evaluate a machine learning system and
search out does it have some kind of
bias just by running it on a bunch of
data and seeing what it does and also
perhaps even more importantly we can fix
this kind of problem if it arises right
so it's probably easier to fix a machine
learning system the screens resumes than
it is just to fix having you know 5000
executives that are slightly sexist or
something right so so in this way there
is a sort of positive angle on using
machine learning in these high-stakes
decisions on the other hand it's been
pretty well known and I know you had a
lecture and bias and fairness that
machine learning often reflects bias in
a data set it can even amplify bias in
the data set and there's concern of kind
of a feedback loop where a biased
algorithm actually will lead to the
creation of more bias data in which case
these problems will only compound and
get
so for all of the high impact decisions
I had listed on that slide there are
examples where things have gone awry
right so Amazon had some AI that was
working as a recruiting tool and it
turned out to be sexist there's been
some kind of early pilots abusing AI in
the justice system and those also have
had in some cases really bad results if
you look at automatic mathematic essay
grading it's not really a great you know
NLP system right so here's an example
excerpt of an essay that a automatic
grading system used by the GRE test
gives a very high score but really it's
just kind of a salad of big fancy words
and that's enough to convince the model
that this is a great essay the last area
that want to talk about where where you
can see there's really some risks and
some pitfalls with using NLP technology
use chat BOTS so I think chat BOTS do
you have a side where they can be very
beneficial robot is one example as this
company that has this chat bot you can
talk to if you're not feeling too great
and it'll try to I don't know cheer you
up so so that you know could be a really
nice piece of technology that helps
people but on the other hand there's
some big risks so so one example is
Microsoft Research had a chat bot
trained on tweets and it started quickly
saying racist things and not to be
pulled so I think all of this highlights
that as NLP is becoming more effective
people are seeing opportunities to use
it in increasingly high stakes decisions
and although you know there's some nice
there's some appeal to that there's also
a lot of risk any more questions on this
sort of social impact of NLP okay last
part of this lecture is looking more
future research right and in particular
I think a lot of the current research
trends are kind of reactions to Bert
right so this the question is what did
Bert solve and what do we work on next
so here are results on the glue
benchmark that is a competing of 10
natural language understanding tasks and
you get an average score across this 10
tasks the left to the 2r sorry the right
to write most models are as non are just
supervised trained machine learning
systems right so we have bag of vectors
we instead use our fancy neural net
architecture of BIOS TM + attention and
we get about 5 points but the gains from
Bert really dwarf that difference right
so sober improves results by about 17
points and we end up being actually
quite close to human performance on
these tasks so one sort of implication
of this that people are wondering about
is is this kind of the death of
architecture engineering so I'm sure all
of you who have worked on the default
final project have seen a whole bunch of
fancy pictures showing different
architectures for solving squad there
are a lot of papers they all propose
some kind of attention mechanism or
something like that and right with Bert
it's sort of you don't need to do any of
that right you just train a transformer
and you give it enough data and actually
you're doing great on squad
you know maybe these architectural
enhancements are not necessarily the key
thing that will drive progress in
improving results on these tasks right
so if you look at this at the
perspective of a researcher you can
think a researcher will say ok I could
spend six months designing a fancy new
architecture for squad and if I do a
good job maybe I'll improve results by
one f1 point but in the case of Bert
increasing the size of their model 3x
which is the difference between they
have like a base size model and a large
model that improved results by 5f1
points
so that does seem to suggest me to sort
of reprioritize which avenues of
research we pursue because this
architecture engineering isn't providing
kind of gains for its time investment
the way leveraging unlabeled data is so
now if you look at the squad leader
board I think at least the top 20
entrants are all Burt plus something one
other issue I think Burt has raised is
that we need harder tasks right Burt has
almost solved squad if you define it by
getting close to human performance so
there's been a growth in new data sets
that are more challenging and there are
a couple ways in which they can be more
challenging so one is doing reading
comprehension and longer documents or
doing it across more than one document
one area is looking at coming up with
harder questions that require multi-hop
reasoning so that essentially means you
have to string together multiple
supporting facts from different places
to produce the correct answer at another
area a situating question answering
within a dialogue there's also been a
kind of small detail with the
construction of reading comprehension
datasets that is actually really
affected the the difficulty of the task
and that is whether when you create
these datasets is the person who writes
questions about a passage can they see
that passage or not so of course it's
much easier to come up with a question
that when you see the passage and if you
come up with a question without seeing
the passage you may not even have a
instable question but the problem with
looking at the passage is that first of
all it's not realistic right so if I'm
asking a question you know I'm not going
to have usually the paragraph that
answers that question sitting in front
of me on top of that it really
encourages easy questions right so if
you're a mechanical turk and you're paid
to write as many questions as possible
and then you see an article that says I
don't know you know Abraham Lincoln was
the 16th President of the United States
what are you going to write as your
question you're gonna write who was the
16th
the United States you're not going to
write something more interesting that's
harder to answer so this is one way in
which crowdsource datasets have changed
people are now making sure questions are
sort of independent of the context so
I'm going to briefly go over a couple
new datasets in this line so one is
called quack which stands for question
answering in context in this data set
there is a teacher and a student the
teacher sees a Wikipedia article the
student wants to learn about this
Wikipedia article and the goal is to
train a machine learning model that asks
as a teacher um so you can imagine maybe
in the future this sort of technology
would be useful for education for kind
of having adding some automation one
thing that makes this task difficult is
that questions depend on the entire
history of the conversation so for
example if you look on the left here the
example dialog the third question is was
he the star clearly you can't answer
that question unless you look back
earlier in the dialogue and realize that
the subject of this conversation is
Daffy Duck and sort of because this data
set is more challenging you can see
there's that there's a much bigger gap
to human performance right so if you
train some Bert with some extensions
you're the results are still like 15 F 1
points worse than human performance
here's one other data set called hotpot
QA it is designed instead for multi hoc
reasoning so essentially in order to
answer a question you have to look at
multiple documents you have to look at
different facts from those documents and
perform some inference to get what the
correct answer is so I think you know
this is a much harder task and again
there's a much bigger gap between human
performance any questions on new data
sets harder chip tasks for NLP okay
I'm gonna kind of rapid-fire and go
through a couple more areas in the last
minutes of this talk so multi-task
learning I think is really growing in
importance of course you've had a whole
lecture on this right so I'm not going
to spend too much time on it but maybe
one point of interest is that if you
look at performance on this glue
benchmark so this benchmark for natural
language understanding all the top
couple results are that are now actually
surpassing Burt and performance or is
taking Burt and training in a multitask
way I think another interesting
motivation for multi task learning is
that if you are training Burt you have a
really really large model and one way to
make more efficient use of that model is
training it to do many things at once
another area that's definitely important
and I think will be important going in
the future is dealing with low resource
settings and here I'm using a really
broad definition of resources right so
that could mean compute power you know
Burt is great but it also takes huge
amounts of compute to run it so it's not
realistic to say if you're building
let's say a mobile Dan app for a mobile
device that you could run a model the
size of Burt as I already went into
earlier in this talk
you know what resource languages is an
area that I think is pretty
underrepresented in NLP research right
now because most datasets are in English
if I do you think right there's a really
you know large number of people that in
order to benefit from NLP technology
we'll need to have technologies that
work well in a lot of different
languages especially those without much
training data and speaking of low
amounts of training data I think in
general this is an interesting area of
research with in machine learning
actually people are working a lot on
this as well I'm so term is often a term
often used as few shot learning and that
essentially means being able to train a
machine learning model that only sees
let's say five or ten
one motivation there is I think a clear
distinction between how our existing
machine learning systems learn and how
humans learn is that humans can
generalize very quickly from five or so
examples if you're training a neural net
you normally need you know thousands of
examples or perhaps even tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands examples
to get something that works so I also
see this being a pretty important area
in the future
the last area where I want to go in a
little bit more depth is interpreting
and understanding models so so really
there's two aspects of this one is if I
have a machine learning model and it
makes a prediction I would like to be
able to know why did it make that
prediction so get some rationale get
some explanation that would especially
be important in an area like healthcare
right so if you're a doctor and you're
making a decision it's probably not good
enough for your machine learning model
to say patient has disease X you really
want it to say patient has disease X for
these reasons because then you as a
doctor can double-check and and try to
validate the the machines thinking I
guess to come up with that diagnosis the
other area of interpreting understanding
models is more of a scientific question
right is we know things like Bert work
really well we want to know why do they
work well what what aspects of language
do they model on what things don't they
model and that might lead to ideas of
improving those those models so here is
a couple slides on the main approach for
a value answering these sort of
scientific questions what does the
machine learning model learn what you do
is you have a model so let's say it's
Bert it takes as input a sequence of
words it produces as output a sequence
of vectors we want to ask does it know
for example the part of speech of words
so so it does in its vector
representations does that capture
something about syntax and a simple way
of asking this question is train another
classifier on top of Bert that's trained
to do wets a part of speech tag
but we only backprop into that
diagnostic classifier itself so in other
word we're treating the output of Bert
that sequence of vectors as a fixed
input and we're sort of probing those
vectors to see do they contain
information about part of speech that
this second diagnostic classifier on top
and can decode to get the correct labels
so it was kind of quite a few concerns
here one concern is if you make your
diagnostic classifier too complicated it
can just solve the classify the task all
on itself and it can basically ignore
whatever representations were produced
by Bert I'm so so the kind of standard
thing right now is to use a single
softmax layer on top of Bert to do these
decisions and there's been a whole bunch
of tasks proposed for evaluating
essentially the linguistic knowledge of
these models so you could do part of
speech tagging you could do more
semantic tasks like relation extraction
or something like coreference
and this is a pretty active area of work
here is just one plot showing some of
the results of this approach so here
what we're doing is we're adding
diagnostic classifiers to different
layers of Bert and we are seeing which
ways of Bert are more useful for
particular tasks and something kind of
interesting comes out of this which is
that the different wears of Bert seem to
be corresponding fairly well with
notions of different ways of way of
linguistics so dependency parsing which
is a syntactic task
it's a consider server you know medium
level task in understanding a sentence
the medium wears of Bert so where is
kind of six through eight or something
are the ones best at dependency parsing
if you have a very semantic tasks like
sentiment analysis where you're trying
to we're in some kind of semantic
property of the whole sentence then the
very last where's of Bert are the one
that seemed to encode the most
information about about this phenomenon
okay so this is almost it for the talk I
just have one slide here of NLP not in
kind of the academic research T contacts
which have already been talking a lot
about but NLP and Industry and really
there's rapid progress there and I want
to point to two areas where I think
there's especially a large interest in
using NLP technology one is dialogue so
for things like chat BOTS right there's
the elec surprise where they're actually
investing a lot of money in having
groups figure out how to improve chat
chat dialogue there's also I think a lot
of potential for customer service right
so improving basically automated systems
that'll you know book you a flight or
help you cancel a subscription or
anything like that and similarly there's
a lot of potential in healthcare one is
understanding the records of someone who
is sick and to help them to help with
diagnosis I think another equally
important area is actually parsing
biomedical papers so the number of
biomedical papers that are being written
is really insane it's way larger than
the number of computer science papers
that are being written often if you are
a doctor or if you're a researcher in
medicine you might want to look up
something very specific right you might
want to know what is the effect of this
particular drug on this particular gene
or a cell with this particular gene
there's no good way right now of
searching through hundreds of thousands
of papers to find if someone has it has
done this experiment and have results
for this particular combination of
things I'm so automated reading of all
this biomedical literature and could
have a lot of value okay to conclude
there's been rapid progress in the last
five years due to deep learning in NLP
in the last year we've seen another
really kind of dramatic increase in the
capability of our systems thanks to
using unlabeled data so that's methods
like Bert and the other kind of thing
that's I think important to think about
is that NLP systems are starting to be
at a place where they can have big
social impact so that makes some issues
and security very important thank you
good luck finishing all your projects
[Applause]